dire
le propriétaire
esprit combatif moral dans le nôtre
personnel militaire
à un niveau élevé maintenant mais tout le monde veut
visiter leur maison pour voir la leur
parents
A mon avis, ils le sont davantage avec une femme
ouvre et te dis où
secrètement, ils ne peuvent pas
répondre
un homme est mieux loti même pour ses proches
parler à un étranger que le sien
Bien sûr, c'est difficile pour moi de rater tout ça
à travers moi
et puis après la conversation
Bien sûr, mon état est déprimé et
il faut en quelque sorte s'en sortir
dur un peu
Difficile pour
personnel, c'est difficile de penser Parfois, tout
en position
à chaque visite ici, il est difficile de penser à quoi
était Pour que quelqu'un ne tombe pas pour moins de 200